[Música]
revista de prensa rosa pérez más deuda
llegamos al viernes finalizamos semana
con esta revista de prensa con la
noticia del día de eeuu el panel del
congreso que investiga el asalto al
capitolio reveló jr hallazgos
preliminares y declaró también que don
absorbe estuvo detrás de este ataque
como lo titula la prensa rusa buenos
dias raúl nos hemos fijado
particularmente en la prensa
estadounidense porque alrededor del
mundo no son tantos los periódicos que
destacan esta información ya que muchos
países tienen lo suyo no a nivel de
política interna me refiero empezamos
por el 'new york times' que dice trump
lideró un intento de golpe de estado
según el panel claramente clara y rasa
esta información y detalla el ex
presidente está acusado de promover el
ataque contra el capitolio el 6 de enero
de 2021 el boston globe dice el mundo
está mirando pruebas del 6 de enero
cuentan la historia y precisa que ayer
en prime time el panel reveló evidencias
nunca antes vistas sobre los intentos de
trampa de revocar el resultado de las
elecciones de 2000 y permanecer así en
el poder y precisamente raúl este
digamos a esta audiencia en prime time
puede ser analizada por una parte como
esta característica estadounidense no y
esta tendencia por el show bussiness
pero también a tal y como señala el wall
street journal puede ser a que lo que
quisiera el comité es llegar a una
máximo número de personas sea posible y
es que el wall street journal señala el
comité que investiga el ataque al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 empezó
una maratón de audiencias públicas con
una sesión en 30 en la noche del jueves
con la intención de convencer a una
nación dividida de que las declaraciones
del ex presidente de donald trump sobre
el sobre que las elecciones fueron
robadas incitaron a sus seguidores a
intentar interrumpir la transferencia
pacífica del poder
ros traemos ahora un especial en
colaboración de una decena de medios de
comunicación de américa latina- sobre el
negocio de la represión de la protesta
en la región ya cambiando radicalmente
de tema exactamente esto es una especial
un reportaje muy intenso con muchos
digamos subtemas a sus artículos pero
queríamos mencionar porque ya para que
cada uno de ustedes entre a indagar en
él desde sus casas pero básicamente este
reportaje habla sobre el negocio de las
armas conocidas como no letales o menos
letales que sirven en general para
controlar a las masas o controlar los
disturbios o tampoco nos engañemos para
reprimir la protesta social en muchas
ocasiones un claro ejemplo de estas
armas que muchos de ustedes conocerán y
algunos habrán padecido son a los gases
lacrimógenos las granadas también de
dispersión los sistemas de lanzamiento
por ejemplo de balas de goma o el venom
aquí en colombiano y este especial
particularmente aborda la adquisición y
su uso en américa latina donde este
equipo de periodistas ha registrado que
al menos 180 personas han muerto o
quedado con secuelas de por vida por
heridas con estas armas y en este
especial podemos ver entre otras cosas
la edad el país o el tipo de lesión de
las distintas víctimas muchas de ellas
por heridas provocadas por la fuerza
pública no usando éstas armas en el
contexto de los estallidos sociales que
han tenido lugar aquí en américa latina
pues en bolivia en ecuador en chile aquí
en colombia en venezuela guatemala en
brasil pero que también usa por ejemplo
eeuu particularmente la guardia
fronteriza contra las personas migrantes
latinoamericanas claro rosa pues de un
informe bastante completo además a
tratando toda esta represión que se vive
en la región e incluso pues como
anécdota también yo también en el
momento en venezuela con el gobierno de
hugo chávez y nicolás maduro cuando
salíamos a las calles a protestar
continuamos en la región rosa pero en el
marco de la guerra en ucrania porque tal
y como señala el 'washington post'
nicaragua autoriza a las tropas aviones
y barcos rusos eso también lo estamos
avanzando nosotros exactamente y por un
lado en la washington post' pues
recupera esta información también
adelantada por la agencia associated
press qué bueno habla de este decreto
que pues emitió el gobierno de daniel
ortega de nicaragua autorizando esta
semana la entrada de las tropas rusas en
el territorio nicaragüense con el
objetivo de entrenar a las autoridades
de seguridad pública con objetivos
también de ayuda humanitaria de misiones
de rescate y búsqueda en emergencias o
desastres naturales y a pesar de que el
gobierno de ortega sea una tradicional
aliado de rusia cabe destacar que este
decreto también autoriza a las mismas
funciones a las fuerzas estadounidenses
o mexicanas y rusia calificó este
decreto de una relación rutinaria sin
embargo veamos cómo la televisión russia
uno puede rusia avanza y habla de esta
nueva cooperación entre nicaragua y
rusia
y la cereza del pastel democrático más
incómoda para eeuu fue el sensacional
anuncio del presidente de nicaragua
daniel ortega que permitió a las tropas
embarcaciones y aviones rusos entrar en
nicaragua
por supuesto sólo para fines
humanitarios las tropas rusas pueden
entrar en nicaragua a partir de la
segunda mitad de 2022
que quieren si los sistemas
estadounidenses de misiles pueden
prácticamente alcanzar moscú desde
territorio ucraniano es el momento de
que rusia despliegue algo poderoso cerca
de eeuu la ciudad brillante sobre la
colina
bueno no sé entonces de esta manera
finalizamos nuestra revista de prensa
por el día de hoy bueno no hay una foto
que nos tiene para mostrarnos rosa y
para cerrar muy rápidamente y es que se
cumple se cumplió esta semana 50 años de
esta fotografía conocida como la niña
del nap al que fue tomada por annie wood
el 8 de junio de 1972 y que está digamos
protagonizada lamentablemente por kim
phuc que ahora tiene ya 59 años no y
cabe pues para destacar una anécdota de
la publicación de esta fotografía que
enseguida dio la vuelta al mundo y es
que el editor de ape de eeuu de la
agencia associated press para la que
trabajaba el fotógrafo en un primer
momento no quería publicarla por la
desnudez de la niña pero fue el editor
de vietnam el que insistió en que era
necesario no publicar y transmitir pues
esta crudeza de la guerra sobre la
población civil y bueno finalmente la
historia de esta foto ya es para todos
conocida y pues para algunos ayudó a
finalizar con esta guerra rosa brasil ha
decido muchísimas gracias por revista de
prensa del día de hoy por toda esta
semana nos vemos el lunes nosotros
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día